[Música]
que tienen los pobres en la cabeza
mucha gente se lo pregunta seguro se lo
escucharon alguna vez a alguien
preguntárselo
que tienen los pobres en la cabeza se lo
preguntan cuando nos ven tener muchos
hijos
cuando nos vean ser violentos cuando nos
ven usar unas zapatillas que parecen
traídas de otro planeta
pero sobre todas las cosas cuando ven
que los pobres seguimos siendo pobres
porque los pobres nos salimos de la
pobreza porque repetimos las historias
nos gusta vivir así
mi nombre es mai de harina y tengo casi
todos los estigmas que se pueda tener de
pobre soy hija de madre adolescente no
tengo padre somos un montón de hermanos
ninguno tiene padres deje la escuela a
los 13 fui mamá a los 14 y podría seguir
pero antes de que se ponga medio
deprimente les quiero contar un
descubrimiento que hice cuando era chica
y que nunca le conté a nadie
lo mantuve en secreto todos estos años y
se los voy a contar hoy
cuando yo era chica soy de villa caracol
una de las villas más pobres de bahía
blanca donde yo crecí no había baño
resolvíamos de este tema como podíamos
pero nadie de la villa tenía baño por
supuesto que yo conocía baños el baño de
la escuela algún baño de algún lugar
público pero nunca había ido al baño de
una casa
una tarde es una amiguita me invite a
jugar a su casa y por supuesto en la
tarde de juego en un momento pido pasar
al baño
cuando pasó mi sorpresa
digo
tienen dos inodoros
porque en una casa
tienen dos senadores digo es uno para
los grandes y otro para los chicos
es una para las mujeres y otro para los
varones pongo a mirarlos bien y descubro
que el segundo inodoro no tiene pozo
sino esta chapita de desagüe entonces
digo ah
ese es el inodoro del pis
el secreto que les quería contar es que
durante años si se pisen olvides de mi
amiga y los giros les voy a contar
esta esta cuerda seguir creyendo que es
ser el ídolo elvis ese es un secreto que
morirá conmigo pero volviendo al tema de
que tenemos los pobres en la cabeza
uno se empieza a dar cuenta que es pobre
más que nada cuando entra en el sistema
escolar
yo me acuerdo cuando empecé el colegio
todos mis compañeritos tenían los útiles
de los dibujitos que les gustaban y yo
ahí con mis útiles del estado
y me acuerdo yo tenía una cartuchera del
hombre araña
y una carpeta de motos y mis compañeras
en su inocencia venían y me decían ah y
esas son cosas de varón
y yo que me moría de ganas por tener
algo como las otras nenas pero jamás lo
iba a reconocer les decía así me
encantan las cosas de varón y al rato de
la nada o aparentemente de la nada
a esa que me decía que mis cosas eran de
barro viva y la agarraba de los pelos
la maestra no entendía nada
era un arranque violento aparentemente
de la nada
la realidad es que la violencia empieza
a ser una forma de vengarse de los demás
por todo eso que ellos tienen y bueno
pero además incorporamos a erróneamente
la idea de que cuando somos violentos
nos tienen otro respeto
porque cuando uno empieza a ser violenta
dejan de preguntar porque tienes las
zapatillas rotas porque tu mochila es
tan vieja porque nunca atrae es lo que
pide la seño porque tus útiles son de
varón
y si no no tengo fotos de mis útiles y
como casi no hay fotos de cuando era
chica tengo para mostrarles
mi disfraz de la época colonial que es
un papel celofán cortado en tiritas y
esta foto la pude recuperar gracias a
que al día de hoy sigo haciendo amiga
del caballero del medio
y después mucha gente se pregunta que
tenemos en la cabeza cuando nos ve
en la juventud de la adolescencia usar
unas zapatillas que cuestan una fortuna
como canta matica rica que cantaba de
300 pesos y ahora la actualizó y canta
de 300 euros
es triste muy bien ahí está ya de 300
pesos no existe
la gente dice por qué usan esa parte
chacón que necesitan fluorescente
gigantes tienen que ser terribles
llantas la realidad es que después de
tantos años
con zapatillas encontrada en la basura o
rescatada de algún lado con útiles del
estado con ropa heredad del primo
con camperas donadas de la iglesia o de
algún vecino después de tantos años de
todo eso el día que te puedes comprar un
par de zapatillas no te alcanza con
poder comprar te lo se tiene que notar
que te la compraste
y sentimos que así van a pensar que no
somos tan pobres
nos sentimos mucho menos pobres con esas
zapatillas sentimos que así nadie se va
a dar cuenta ya todos los años que
pasamos con zapatillas encontradas en la
basura
pero además
de que usamos estas zapatillas traídas
de otro planeta y de que somos violentos
porque creemos que así nos van a
respetar o que así nos vengamos de todo
lo que tienen los otros
además son los vados
no sé si alguna vez tuvieron un albañil
laborando en su casa pero yo les puedo
asegurar que el tipo lunes no aparece si
sé por qué por qué no trabajan no nos
gusta trabajar vivimos de planes o
muchos dicen antes no había planes
y éramos igual
la realidad es que
esto viene marcado desde la infancia y
hay una diferencia muy grande con la que
yo insisto siempre y es que no es lo
mismo la pobreza estructural que la
pobreza esporádica la pobreza esporádica
la han conocido la mayoría de los
argentinos es cuando el jefe o jefa de
familia
se quedó sin trabajo se conocieron los
videos blancos se empezó a caminar en
vez de andar en auto
y se sobrevivió pero siempre tuvieron a
sus padres trabajando todos los días o
saliendo a buscar laburo todos los días
y sobre todas las cosas mandando los a
la escuela todos los días
los que crecemos en la pobreza
estructural los que crecemos en los
márgenes de la sociedad vamos a la
escuela cuando podemos
cuando se puede jamás nadie nos enseña
que hay que cumplir algo de lunes a
viernes
jamás adquirimos la costumbre de
madrugar todos los días y como ustedes
saben todo lo que uno no aprende de
chico es muy difícil incorporarlo de
grande
y después ocurre que los empleadores te
dicen nuevo contrato un pib no viene
nunca siempre le pasaba algo pierde el
colectivo porque porque no vamos a
trabajar la realidad es que no tenemos
incorporado el ritmo laboral
pero cuando más se pregunta a la gente
que tenemos en la cabeza los pobres
es cuando nos ven tener muchos hijos
la gente se desespera cuando ve que los
pobres tenemos hijos y yo después de
contarles esto
de que somos violentos porque creemos
erróneamente que así nos van a respetar
y es que usamos estas zapatillas porque
creemos que así nos vamos a ver menos
pobres
y de que somos vagos porque no tenemos
incorporado el ritmo laboral
me gustaría tener algo más anecdótico o
más entretenido para explicarles por qué
tenemos hijos pero es mucho más simple
los pobres tenemos hijos porque es lo
único que podemos tener
y tenemos muchos
porque encontramos en cada hijo una
razón para levantarnos todos los días a
pesar de nuestra pobreza
y ustedes eran porque esta piba que
creció así y que cuenta que vivió así
hoy está parada acabas contándoles esto
y es una pregunta legítima
la realidad es que
una familia que te invita a su casa a
jugar
te enseña mucho más que usar el baño
te enseña que la vida puede ser de otra
manera que te la puedes ganar de otra
manera y que la puedes vivir de otra
manera
pero no solamente yo aprendí de ellos
esos ellos también lo aprendieron de mí
y de mi familia
y yo no sé si ustedes son el amigo que
presta el baño o el amigo que se
sorprende del baño del otro amigo pero
está bueno juntarse con gente con un
baño diferente y no solo por el hecho
de que te enseña que hay otras maneras
de ver la vida sino por lo más
importante
y lo que a mí me llevó muchísimos años
entender pues yo estuve muchos años muy
enojada por los útiles los disfraces las
zapatillas
pero entendí
que nadie elige con que vayan a hacer
yo sé que hemos avanzado mucho los
argentinos como sociedad muchísimo sé
que antes era un crimen ser homosexual y
hoy en cambio nos parece un escándalo
que se ataque alguien por su sexualidad
antes era un pecado ser mujer y
pretender hacer algo más que nos fueran
las tareas del hogar y hoy en cambio es
un escándalo que nos quieran asignar una
tarea por el hecho de ser mujeres y yo
celebro que nos escandalicemos ante esas
cosas pero hay algo antes ante lo que no
nos escandalizamos
no nos escandalizamos con la pobreza
o por la calle y vemos un tipo durmiendo
a la intemperie y no nos escandaliza
o por la calle y vemos un pibito
pidiendo o vendiendo en vez de estar
jugando
y no nos escandaliza
yo no vine acá a dar esta charla para
pedirles que se escandalicen ahora todo
el tiempo cada vez que ven un pobre y
que corran a invitarlo a pasar a su baño
lo que viene a decirles
es esta idea que tengo de que es una
injusticia que a los pobres se nos
condene por no ser educados pero nadie
se pregunta jamás si recibimos educación
y a los pobres se nos condena por no ser
respetuosos pero nadie se pregunta si
alguna vez recibimos respeto
y si me pongo un poco más sentimental y
abstracta a los pobres se nos juzga
mucho por ser fríos por no ser amorosos
pero nadie se pregunta nunca si alguna
vez recibimos amor
a mí me gustaría
decirles
yo sé que cuesta mucho entender
como somos y que tenemos en la cabeza y
sé que es muy difícil comprender y
ponerse en los zapatos del otro y sé que
muchas veces se enojan cuando nos ven
ser como somos
pero cada hora cuando salen de él cada
vez que se crucen un villero un pobre
marginal
porque se van a cruzar porque somos un
montón porque estamos por todos lados y
porque no somos invisibles como muchos
dicen
pero cuando se lo crucen antes de
enojarse antes de preguntarse qué tienen
estos tipos en la cabeza me gustaría que
piensen
si se hubieran enojado con una nena que
les hizo pis el bidet porque nunca había
visto un baño muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]